Digamos que me encuentro aquí y voy a plantear
dos escenarios. En uno de los escenarios soy
un observador. Este soy yo, quizá mejor debería
dibujar mi globo ocular porque vamos a observar
la luz, así que sólo dibujaré mi globo ocular.
Así que este soy yo en el primer escenario,
o este es uno de mis ojos. Y luego este es uno
de mis ojos en el segundo escenario. Ahora,
en ambos escenarios vamos a tener un objeto
que será algún tipo de fuente de luz,
pero en el primer escenario esta fuente de luz
permanecerá estática con respecto a mí, mientras
que en el segundo escenario la fuente de luz
como parte de la discusión y sólo por diversión,
se va a mover a la mitad de la velocidad de
la luz, que es una velocidad inimaginablemente
rápida. Pero supongamos que así se mueve, a
una velocidad de ½ de la velocidad de la luz,
y esta fuente tan rápida se aleja de mí que soy
el observador. Imaginemos lo que pasa en ambos
escenarios. Ambos tienen una fuente de luz y
ambos comenzarán a emitir luz al mismo tiempo,
y cuando empiezan a emitir luz ambos están
exactamente a la misma distancia de mi ojo;
la única diferencia es que en el primer escenario
la fuente de luz está estacionaria con respecto a
mí, mientras que en el segundo escenario la fuente
de luz se aleja de mí a la mitad de la velocidad
de la luz. Entonces digamos que después de cierto
periodo de tiempo la onda de luz de esta fuente
llega a mi ojo, y luego luce algo así. Trataré
de dibujarlo lo mejor posible. Quiero dibujar
un par de longitudes de onda aquí. Digamos que
es la mitad de la longitud de onda, esa es una
longitud de onda completa, eso es otra mitad;
una longitud de onda completa, otra mitad, una
longitud de onda completa. Luego la mitad y luego
una longitud de onda completa. Permíteme ver si
puedo dibujar esto, que se vería como una longitud
de onda completa, longitud de onda completa,
longitud de onda completa. No es fácil de hacer. Y
luego tienes otra longitud de onda completa que se
vería algo así, la forma de onda real. Y entonces
el frente de la onda está llegando a mi ojo,
y luego, a medida que las formas de onda continúan
pasando por mi ojo, mi ojo percibirá algún tipo
de longitud de onda o frecuencia, y lo percibirá
como algún tipo de color, suponiendo que la fuente
de luz está en la parte visible del espectro
electromagnético. Ahora pensemos en lo que pasa
con esta fuente. Lo primero es que el frente
de la forma de onda me alcanzará exactamente
al mismo tiempo que la del primer escenario. Una
de las cosas asombrosas sobre cómo viaja la luz,
en general, especialmente en el vacío, es que
no importa que la fuente se aleje de mí a la
mitad de la velocidad de la luz, la luz seguirá
moviéndose hacia mí a la velocidad de la luz,
es absoluto, no importa si esto desaparece a 0.9
de la velocidad de la luz, la luz seguirá viajando
hacia mí a la velocidad de la luz. Y es muy poco
intuitivo porque nuestro sentido común nos dice
que si me estoy alejando de ti a la mitad de
la velocidad de una bala y disparo una bala,
se resta la mitad de la velocidad y la bala se
moverá hacia ti a la mitad de su velocidad normal,
si el disparo hubiera sido estacionario. Pero así
no sucede con la luz. Con esto en mente, pensemos
en cómo se vería la forma de onda. Entonces,
para cuando la luz llega aquí. Permíteme volver
a dibujar esto aquí y volver a dibujar este globo
ocular aquí; aquí estoy yo. Recuerda que ambas
fuentes de luz comenzaron a emitir luz al mismo
tiempo y esta fuente ha recorrido la mitad de esta
distancia. Si a la luz le tomó una cierta cantidad
de tiempo llegar hasta acá, su fuente recorrerá
la mitad de esa distancia en la misma cantidad
de tiempo, así que para cuando la luz alcanza
a mi ojo la fuente habrá viajado la mitad de esta
distancia, habrá llegado hasta acá, recorrió toda
esta distancia. Ambas fuentes comenzaron a emitir
luz al mismo tiempo, por lo que ese primer fotón,
si consideras a la luz como una partícula, llegará
a mi ojo al mismo tiempo que el primer fotón de
esta fuente. Entonces la forma de onda se estirará
de manera que seguimos teniendo una, dos, tres,
cuatro longitudes de onda completas. Pero ahora
éstas se estirarán. Déjame ver si puedo dibujar
cuatro longitudes de onda completas. Voy a cortar
esto por la mitad aquí, y cortar cada uno de estos
por la mitad. Entonces, cada uno de estos será
una luz de onda completa y luego tendrá media
longitud de onda en el medio, por lo que la forma
de onda se verá así. Trataré de dibujarlo lo mejor
posible. Esta es la parte más difícil, dibujar
la forma de onda estirada. Y ahí tienes, se verá
así. Entonces, cuando llegue a mi ojo, mi ojo lo
percibirá como si tuviera una longitud de onda
más larga, aunque desde la perspectiva de cada
una de las fuentes, si te mantienes junto a cada
una de ellas en todo momento, la frecuencia y la
longitud de onda de la luz que emiten es la misma;
la única diferencia es que esta fuente se está
alejando de mí o yo me estoy alejando de ella,
dependiendo de cómo quieras verlo, mientras que
en este primer caso tanto el observador como la
fuente están estacionarios. Ahora, en esta
situación, ¿qué va a percibir mi ojo? Bueno,
mi ojo captará cada uno de estos pulsos o cada uno
de estos trenes de ondas sucesivos, y va a decir
"Oye, hay una longitud de onda más larga aquí,
yo percibo una longitud de onda más larga". Voy
a escribirlo: se percibe una longitud de onda más
larga aquí y también se percibe una frecuencia más
baja. Entonces, ¿qué le hará esto a la percepción
de la luz? Digamos que esta luz es de color verde,
por lo que si la fuente de luz está estacionaria
igual que el observador, él la verá de color
verde. Veamos el espectro electromagnético. Esto
lo copié de Wikipedia. Entonces, si la fuente de
luz está estacionaria con respecto al observador,
estaríamos en la parte de luz verde del espectro,
es decir, una longitud de onda de 500 nanómetros;
pero si de pronto la fuente de luz se aleja del
observador a esta enorme velocidad, la longitud de
onda percibida se vuelve más ancha. Y puedes ver
lo que está pasando aquí, se verá más rojo,
se mueve hacia la parte roja del espectro.
Y este fenómeno se llama Corrimiento al rojo, y
tenemos muchos videos en la lista de Física sobre
el Efecto Doppler, y allí hablo de las ondas
sonoras y la frecuencia percibida del sonido:
si algo se acerca a ti en lugar de que se
aleje de ti, que es exactamente la misma idea,
este es el Efecto Doppler aplicado a la luz. Y la
razón por la que el Efecto Doppler funciona para
la luz que viaja a través del espacio y para el
sonido que viaja a través del aire es porque la
onda de sonido en el aire, independientemente de
si la fuente se está alejando o se está acercando,
la onda de sonido se moverá a la velocidad del
sonido en el aire a cierta presión y todo eso,
y con la luz en el vacío sucede lo mismo, siempre
e independientemente del movimiento de la fuente,
la onda de luz real siempre viajará a la misma
velocidad, la única diferencia es que cambiará
la frecuencia y la longitud de onda percibidas.
Y la razón por la que estoy hablando de esto es
porque puedes usar esta propiedad de la luz del
Corrimiento al rojo para ver si las cosas se
alejan o se acercan a ti. Y la gente habla
del Corrimiento al rojo porque francamente
la mayoría de las cosas se alejan de nosotros,
esa es una de las razones por las que tendemos
a creer en el Big Bang. Por el contrario, si
algo viaja hacia ti a velocidades súper altas,
entonces tendríamos algo llamado Corrimiento
al violeta o desplazamiento al violeta,
donde la frecuencia percibida se incrementa, por
lo que se vería más azul o más púrpura. Ahora,
otra cosa que quiero resaltar es que este fenómeno
de Corrimiento al rojo no se aplica sólo a la luz
visible, también se puede aplicar a las cosas
que ni siquiera podemos ver. Podría aplicarse
a ondas que ya son rojas y que al alejarse se
vuelven más rojas, aunque no las podamos ver;
la onda emitida podría ser de microondas, pero
debido a que la fuente se aleja tan rápidamente
de nosotros podemos percibir la onda como
una onda de radio. De hecho, debí mencionar
esto en el video sobre la radiación de fondo de
microondas que la percibimos como microondas,
pero que esas fuentes se están alejando de
nosotros, por lo que están corridos al rojo,
por lo que, en realidad las fuentes no
emiten radiación de microondas, es sólo
que lo que observamos es en realidad radiación
de microonda, y eso se predice con base en el
Big Bang. De cualquier manera espero que esto te
dé una idea de lo que es el Corrimiento al rojo y
puedas usar esta herramienta para explicar por
qué pensamos que muchas, muchas cosas se están
alejando de nosotros. Y ahora quiero asegurarme
de que entiendas esta idea. Si tengo dos objetos,
digamos que son dos soles, estrellas o son dos
galaxias o lo que sea, debido a otras propiedades,
que no mencionaré en este momento, sabemos
que probablemente emiten luz del mismo color
y sabemos esto porque conocemos otras propiedades
de esas estrellas o galaxias, pero si lo que
realmente percibimos es que este nos parece más
rojo que este, entonces sabemos que el primero
se está alejando de nosotros, y cuanto más rojo
se vea, mientras más se extienda su longitud de
onda en relación con esta otra estrella, más
rápidamente se estará alejando de nosotros.